if you were a fighter what would be your
nickname yeah and and what would be your
walkout music my nickname would be the
monster and the monster is based on an
old joke where it's like the monster's
the guy that like bangs the fat chick so
you guys can all bang the the Kentucky
ones that's how we're starting this okay
so that's what I would do I would bang
the chick who holds the purses while you
guys get yourself going no your name
would be the grenade yeah well I'm the
guy who jumps on the grenade jump on the
ground I called it the monster back of
my day prank just froze yeah Frank's not
ready for that this old school comic
talk because it has to rhyme with your
nickname right like Sam the tornado
Tripoli oh there you go the monster
Tripoli doesn't work he calls me the
monster that's cause you're a good
comedy boss okay yeah and I [ __ ] fat
chicks all right well okay coming in hot
okay we are we're not gonna win this
YouTube show already monetized oh is it
tour oh yeah it's too early 10 minutes
that's all right we're live who cares